having a swarm of rats crawl up your
legs may
seem like your own personal nightmare
but for hollywood animal trainer mark
harden
it's just another day of work to teach
them to climb up his pants for the 2003
movie willard
multiple rats had to repeat the task
over and over again at different angles
at the beginning we certainly want to
make it as easy as possible give them as
much confidence as possible and then we
gradually make it more difficult but
being a rat trainer
isn't just about getting a rat to run
from point a to point b
although that is a big part of it it's
also about
understanding the unique personality of
every rat you cast
rats are social animals that can be
trained
just like a cat or a dog and they have a
similar genetic makeup to humans
and just like humans they can have a
variety of behaviors and personalities
which means rat trainers need to be able
to sort through them
and identify their strengths and
weaknesses
for each main rat character in a film
mark actually needs to find
multiple rat actors to play the part in
willard
mark used six different rats to play the
main
white rat socrates who was on camera
most of the film
doing a variety of specialized tricks
this guy's a really good runner this guy
seems pretty handleable and stable so if
my actors have to hold him this will be
my accurate so you sort of slot them
into the arc of the character
a horde of rats is called a mischief and
once mark has cast the mischief
the rats need to be sorted by what they
can and will do
henry ford would be very proud of how we
train rats
in the groups and he has trained a lot
of rats even for a single project
300 for bram stoker's dracula and
600 for willard after casting the first
step
is to split them up by gender so they
don't reproduce while filming
then he splits them into smaller groups
and puts them into boxes based on their
assigned tasks
which is based on what they're good at
according to the trainer's observation
each box might have a different trainer
or trainers in charge of it they might
start out with five rats in a box
and eventually they would work their way
up to 20 at a time
to keep track of who is who all rats are
tagged on their tail
with a different color marker it was a
team effort i didn't orc
i didn't sit there and have you know 600
rats on a leash
one of the types of rats he wants to
identify early on
are the more aggressive rats or biters
for safety reasons
yes rats do bite people and mark himself
has been bitten but in general
they won't go out of their way to attack
someone so we encourage
biting certain things but what you would
hand to an actor would be one that
you're
100 sure is not a fighter but let's say
he
does want the rat to bite something on
camera in this case
a rat that likes to chew is exactly what
he'd want
the trick is putting food near the
object
then eventually putting the food inside
the object
a biter rat will chew its way through to
get to it just like they do in this
scene from willard with the newspaper
and this scene with the tires mark
creates a special mixture of nut butter
and food coloring which he paints on a
prop for example
in this scene in willard the rats were
actually chewing fake balsa wood legs
covered in this edible paste if i want
him to look like he's biting a finger
i'll just put some
scent on the finger not enough to make
him want to taste it but enough to make
him interested
if a real bite is required close up on
camera
usually a prosthetic is used with fake
blood of course
no matter what the rat's personality or
specialty is
they all have one trait in common the
problem with rats is they're very
sound sensitive and smell sensitive and
they're very
very tactile so when you're training
them
as soon as you move it's all different
right
the first smell that walks through that
they don't recognize
they shut down so the more details about
a set he knows in advance
the better so he can prepare them for
anything let's look at this scene in
true blood that mark worked on as an
example
a rat needed to run on dirt through a
tunnel while a camera was pushing
towards him
it then had to crawl through a grate and
run to a mark
where it would then stand on its hind
legs and transform into a human
so mark needed to first identify a good
runner rat who could deal with these
obstacles
he replicated what it would look like as
much as possible in his training area
using a simple dog toy on a paint stick
to mimic the camera
and how did he get the rat to move in
the first place
no matter the personality he has to use
several basic behavior modification
tools to get it to do what he wants on
command
first is positive reinforcement in which
he rewards the rats with food
after the trick is complete or he might
reward them with
safety by giving them what's called a
sanctuary we have little
plastic shoe boxes with a little mouse
hole cut in it they're dark
they're black they're very attractive to
a rat
their food's in there so we start
introducing them to the concept of food
and sanctuary at the same time
but food alone isn't going to get a rat
to run
often mark also has to take advantage of
its flight
reaction by making a loud sound a rat is
built to deal with stress if you don't
give them any stress they tend to do
self-destructive behaviors
anyway so their whole psychology is
built from
scurrying from this thing to that thing
for the true blood scene
mark made a makeshift rattle with
pebbles to get the rat to run
and rewarded it with a sanctuary at the
end where it would get
food and then we start increasing the
distance
we add a buzzer to it so we're calling
them giving them some aversion to being
here and
while we're calling them there so by the
time you get on set you usually just the
buzzer
is enough but if he goes sideways or
something you might want to
shake your little stick to get the rat
to hit its final mark he used an
almond oil scent so it knew where to
stop
he uses this same basic method when he
needs specialized
tricks like jumping or climbing they
behave well on props
you know they can walk tightropes and go
up ladders and do things like that
let's say he wants a rat to jump in a
scene a more difficult trick for a rat
he puts the food behind him on a
platform so the rat has to use his
shoulder as a bridge to get it
then he gradually increases the distance
so it has to hop over
or if he wants it to climb his leg as we
mentioned
earlier he puts the food at waist level
off camera so it needs to go up his leg
to get to it
and sometimes he needs to adjust the
props to give the rats
a boost for example in willard they
created a set of prop
steps that the rats could easily run
down that were much shorter than the
ones crispin glover would use
now working with a single rad is one
thing but what happens when he needs a
whole group to do something
how do their personalities change the
groups become individuals
you know i mean if you have a group of
300 rats you break it down into
manageable pieces and those pieces each
become an
individual and each rat needs to learn
the trick
they won't follow the herd or follow a
leader like
pigeons or other flock animals as groups
they're all
stupid one rat will never lead another
group of
a group of rats through something
difficult but one rat will stop an
entire army of rats
a common scene with rats in movies is
swarms of them running together from one
point to another
let's look at an example of how a group
of some runners were trained for willard
mark starts by putting each box one at a
time on top of a table in the middle of
a room
he opens it and has them run to a
different sanctuary box at the other end
he does this on a table both to get them
out of their comfort zone
and so they're easier to control they
naturally want to hug a wall
so i'm in the movie making business so
anything they want to do naturally we
train against because
chances are that's not what you want in
the movie he will gradually lower the
table until the rats learn to run on the
floor
and then we start introducing them to
multiple
surfaces they'll run over carpet they'll
run over wood they'll run over tile
we'll put water we'll put
dirt we'll put whatever they need lastly
he preps the groups together on the
actual set
usually two rehearsals is enough in
groups
rats all need to be weighed two to three
times per day
to make sure they are all eating and
healthy
faster smarter rats in the group will
get to the food
first more often so mark occasionally
needs to identify and remove them to let
the other rats get the prize
so a lot of time on set is spent just
making sure the animals
are all safe and healthy and just how
strong is their group identity
we would prep the blue team then we
would prep the red team and then we'd
turn them all loose and see what
they would do and we kept track and
about 85 percent of the rats ended up in
their own
boxes many films these days use
cgi to create realistic animals like
rats
but with cgi you're also losing the
personality that comes with the real
thing
it's really less dynamic and less
dramatic
and you just wouldn't get the same
visceral reaction
watching a bunch of cgi rats crawl up a
human leg
as you would with a real swarm on one
time in the rehearsal
the rat one rat got inside my pant leg
and that just freaked me out because you
got a hundred rats on the outside and
one on the inside and it was a freakiest
feeling